don't get too close to your computer
screen or you might get pregnant I know
that it's almost no fabric I know that
in high school and in middle school
girls wore them above their belt line
the thing that comes to mind the most is
that thong by Cisco the thong song I
think it's gonna feel like my genitals
are getting a hug I don't typically like
things near my butthole regions like one
wrong move bang bong rips no butthole
and a half look at the back I didn't
imagine it to be this lazy where does
this trip go whoa
there's no Tulsa poor Dennis hi hunting
in the huff oh we're it's like a sling
that covers one testicle there is a
piece of string in between my butt
cheeks and it feels foreign
see I don't know what happened I was
when I got back from putting them on I
was okay and then I had to adjust and
then I we made it worse and I don't know
what happened exactly
I don't know how to make it better I had
to use the bathroom one time and putting
the thong back into position was it was
a little unusual room
so um pee and it's exceptionally easier
to pee with this thong on because
there's not much there to pee
I'm surrounded by women who are laughing
at me right now yeah my butt is
uncomfortable I'm like waddling a little
bit as I walk we're walking to Chipotle
god it's like riding up my crack
and it's hot as [ __ ] out here I'm not
used to the way this feels yet but I
have noticed that it's kind of an
interesting feeling knowing I've got a
secret the amazing thing about the phone
is I feel remarkably fast in it y'all
it's really wrapping up my soul but it
doesn't feel that bad I kind of like it
my my business flops around a little bit
but other than that I feel aerodynamic
it's not as comfortable as I was
expecting it to be to be honest I feel
like I could wear this to the gym every
time I go down to do it that lifts it
rides up my butt crack which is a little
unpleasant there were roses and there
were thorns to it there were highs and
they were lows I never quite got used to
the feeling of fabric running up and
down my butt crack did I feel sexy of
course I did did I feel ridiculous of
course I did but it's because I have a
penis I give y'all mad props like y'all
always have string stuck up you're like
that's not something I really want to do
every day but it wasn't as uncomfortable
as I thought it would be